the Joe Rogan experience you're on a
plane that's not going anywhere it's I'm
blown away by the amount of rules like
I've believed it at the gate for like
two hours before I'm like I just go back
into the airport and they're like now
like it doesn't make any sense you leave
and not like take the flight but I wanna
I'm off going I think you can be left
the doors closed it's a big deal if you
want to leave that's a big deal but as a
Puerto Rican if you do leave Luis you
have to twerk on your own if you watch
those videos when people leave playing
go fine yeah we have to work their way
up you will get put on a list for sure
of your [ __ ] every time you fly on a
plane
it already has that problem am i
guessing do you think that they would
probably check you around now I decided
I want off the plane right now and if
you make a scene you know yeah pull the
plane back into them like this guy I
don't think you're not gonna get off
unless you make a scene you won't get
off ones away from the gate I'm talking
about when they stay at the gate and
they never actually pull away from like
the UH you're on a plane you're just
hoping everyone can keep it together
yeah hoping just hoping everyone can
keep it what's your craziest plane
experience I never I keep flying and
I've had plenty of weird ones two dudes
did almost get after it
once on a plane over overhead space this
one guy was claiming the space overhead
there's only four or five argument you
could have on a plane middle person gets
one guy was on this side right but his
[ __ ] was all filled up so he opens up
the bin on the other side and puts his
bag in and sits down on the guy who was
behind him that was his side he goes hey
man that's my storage space he goes no
it's not he goes it's storage space I
put my bag in there first I wasn't I was
ahead of you I put my bag in there he's
like no you have yours and I have mine
and yours is full and he goes to grab
his [ __ ] yeah and the guy goes hey man
don't touch my [ __ ] bag that guy's
right by the way the guy who took the
the other storage space you don't have
[ __ ] off dude it's just storage sorry
one first class I wish one of those
degenerate [ __ ] from the back would try
to put some [ __ ] muscle
I feel first one time they almost went
after it though the waitress had to cut
them off so you caught them we're in the
air the waitress we're in the air and
they're going at it again so it's like
we they're going at it when they're
about the plane was about to take off
and then they got through it and then in
the air they were going at it again the
waitress
the stewardess she cuts them off
wouldn't let them have alcohol but it
was tense so it's like you know you have
to keep an eye on I was gonna say like
the whole tarji the lady made me she's
like you're gonna help me right I'm like
Jesus Christ lady anything's gonna
happen well yes sir all right the woman
behind me as I was complaining she was I
was like I was like yeah you know he's
like what what do you guys do I was like
smaller juice of coffee maybe a kind bar
that'd be nice because I said like loud
enough for me she goes just get him some
orange juice and I want to turn around
was like mind your business lady shut
the [ __ ] up these guys those undercover
dudes that are on planes air marshals
air marshals right so if you're an Air
Marshal and you see these two two guys
getting after a little bit just talking
[ __ ] grabbing bags to shoot them Dickey
to each other when do you move in
because you don't want everybody to know
you're an Air Marshal you like they
don't have a bomb guys got to work this
out you [ __ ] [ __ ] are just gonna
push each other like you're not you know
you guys aren't terrorists what am I
doing here this is just an architect and
a [ __ ] if somebody's wanted a fight
there's a plane and give up their entire
[ __ ] it's such a pain in the ass what
did you're going to deal with to get
into a fistfight on a plane I don't know
how many different crimes it is I've
done but they have to pull this [ __ ]
plane over you are [ __ ] dude you have to
really want to fight somebody in order
to do that because you'll deal with a
lot of [ __ ] to that plane you're gonna
like wanton ammonia rescue your vote
your saw that lady smack her boyfriend
in the head the guy gets up he's trying
to leave and she throws the laptop and
yeah as he's walking down the aisle yeah
screaming starts throwing laptop yeah
you ain't [ __ ]
she's fired she catch her boyfriend
cheating on the plane or something like
that was but she got super loud and it
became like a huge scene where everybody
was listening to her talk and him was
like oh my god this is so crazy I mean
when they were dragging the asian guy
out of the planes one of the funniest he
start chanting I want to go home but it
was so sad I wouldn't legitimately have
to drag back if they were trying to get
me to give up my seat they would have to
drag me out of the plane imagine
thinking they could do that we're just
gonna grab you physically and take you
off the show like come on you're you're
you're on the plane the planes about to
take off we're gonna grab you and just
pull you out of there and I think they
probably just settled with him they
probably just gave him a ton of money
and said shut the [ __ ] up here's at what
point it is your prize find out what
business they do have security I mean
what point does somebody wants to leave
your private business I'm sure it's
within the the contract that you [ __ ]
the Terms of Service for the ticket that
they can do that so you think so we're
the guys already sitting down well he
said yeah no after they asked him to
leave a lot of times so I don't know
what the law is I mean if it's his
ticket and he bought the ticket you can
just decide Terms of Service so
ridiculous exactly you're right Louis
just say it's a Terms of Service dumb
line they can do anything they want